Start
Think about it
what is this
circle
Almost
But still wrong
Now let's take a look at two shapes
Left and right
Which shape is more suitable for "Bouba"?
Which is more suitable for "Kiki"?
About 98% think the shape on the left is Kiki and the one on the right is Bouda.
And the results have nothing to do with the region and age.
The results of experiments in different language cultures are consistent.
Then, what does this mean?
From this research, we can understand
How does the brain go in a unified way?
Give abstract meaning to different shapes.
And how the directors used this discovery to tell their story.
The best practice is naturally in animation.
In animation, the painter can create objects and characters with whatever shape they want.
Let's start with the simplest shape:
Circles, squares and triangles.
It looks very simple, but these graphics can express far more than you think.
Evil characters are like Kiki
Their shapes are relatively sharp
A pointed nose with long, curved fingers.
And the cute image is designed to be the same as Bouda.
Soft, round.
Is it that the name of the uninhibited character in the animation is Baloo is just a coincidence?
I think these are the embodiment of intuition.
Our brain has always been more threatening to think of sharp things.
"The top is too round and should be sharp."
"There is no deterrent of the circle"
"The sharp point is scary"
You see, these three circles draw the best and best known animated characters.
At the same time, I also noticed that evil characters are just a combination of various triangles.
Slightly touch up
This way you can express your emotions in a way that is not easily noticeable.
I have always seen it in my favorite movie clips.
When we saw the weird bad guys turn from Kiki to round, the weak Bouba
You might think that this only applies to animations.
But it is a coincidence that Das Vader’s mask has this shape,
And the main dark helmet, Darth Vader's cartoon comedy and imitation,
Have this shape?
One of the sharpest villains is the Sleeping Curse.
They even tried to keep the sharp chin and eyebrows in the real remake.
In other words, do you use "party" to describe what someone wants to express?
This means they are bored or they are out of date.
But "square" also implies that it is solid and stable.
Deja vu?
The square is rigid and not easy to change.
If the development of the situation is not what they envision, they are likely to be a little angry.
"You are looking for it, try this!"
"Ah, ah, ah ah ah!!!"
If you really want to look at the abstract
The movie world behind a rectangular camera lens.
Many important geometric shapes come from the picture.
The most noteworthy framing is probably picture-in-picture
This technique is used to represent an image trapped in an existing situation.
*Various car speakers*
Another unfamiliar but equally important picture-in-picture framing method is a circular viewfinder.
Brings a geometric impression of surveillance and spying.
*noise*
Going further than picture-in-picture, you can use lines to create visual prisons in the picture.
Whether it's an office in a blind or a computer screen,
The combination of vertical and horizontal lines implies that a character is his or her existing lifestyle.
Prisoners and slaves.
These lenses use geometric vision as a means of storytelling.
"From the time I remembered, I always wanted to be a robber."
We didn't even notice that there were lines everywhere in the picture.
Geometry is everywhere, obeying the same principles.
The balance of power that triangles can emphasize,
Linear screens can show physical separation,
Or a straight line can guide our sight.
So, the next time you watch a favorite movie, you can try to analyze the geometric layout of the picture and the characters.
If you do this, you are in good shape.
"What about this?"
"Several lines of wavy lines?..."
"Sorry."
"This is not your lucky day!"
Thanks for watching.
First of all, thanks to Good Blood, I got the inspiration for making this film from his amazing crash kangaroo video. highly recommended!